from kate
i have an unusual problem michael
oh my i've struggled with large breasts
my whole life i know the first reaction
guys have when they hear this i guess i
just demonstrated that reaction however
it can be difficult to work out clothes
are a struggle and more importantly i
have chronic back pain what is the
general christian consensus on surgeries
like breast reductions and even breast
implants well those would be two
different
those would be two different issues on
the question of a breast reduction if
it's a medical problem and you're having
a surgery to improve your health and
solve a medical problem there would be
nothing wrong with that
if
and you can bring in breast implants on
this aspect of the question because i
don't see how getting breast implants
would help your problem it seems like it
would hurt your problem if
if the reason that you're having breast
surgery or any other kind of cosmetic
surgery is for your own vanity
if it's for your own
desire to incite lust among people uh
that would be no good
if you're having a breast surgery like
breast implants for instance that
destroy
mammary glands that destroy working
organs that that would be no bueno that
is that's not something that you would
be
you would be permitted to do in the
christian understanding of things
but if you're going to get the surgery
just because you're you're going to
break your back otherwise that's
perfectly fine you don't have anything
to worry about there do you not get
enough respect i'll tell you me i get no
respect no respect i tell you well that
was true before i became a lord that's
right i am lord michael knowles i can
prove it i've got my certificate from
established titles which is a terrific
way to play on an old scottish custom to
to refer to landowners as lards or lords
and ladies in english with established
titles you will get your title pack you
will receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
with your certificate you can officially
change your name to lord or lady you can
get it on your credit card or airplane
tickets you can put it on your dating
profiles it's a great way to connect
with your family if you happen to be
scottish it's a great way to get some
respect if you're like me and it helps
to
preserve nature because established
titles has partnered with a lot of
really great conservation charities so
you're helping the planet while you do
it they're having an extended new year
sale right now head on over to
establishtitles.com
knowles save 10 off today remember to
use the discount code knowles kles or
just click the link below that is
established titles dot com slash knowles
we should change that url though it
should be slash lord knowles
i'll talk to established titles head on
over there become a lord or a lady
yourself
[Music]
[Music]
you